yes the fastest cars in the quarter mile
back in las vegas this weekend it is the
nhra for the dodge nhra finals
up at las vegas motor speedway and for
the first time since the pandemic
started
fans are going to get to watch
professional sports here in las vegas
very exciting so
joining us to talk about the event and
all the fan safety jeff motley from las
vegas motor speedway joins us again jeff
good to talk with you one more time
let's backtrack a little bit and talk
about the safety protocols that are in
place
we know the speed we wanted to have fans
for the nascar races what's in place now
for the drag strip
well it's going to be a little bit
different every fan that comes in
they're going to give it a temperature
check they're going to have their bag
checked
all their tickets are going to be
digital we're not going to have any
paper tickets so we're not going to
actually touch your cell phone but your
tickets will be on your cell phone
and then once you get inside everything
is going to be cashless if you want a
concession stand item
a souvenir it's going to be done through
your credit card there'll be no cash
and then all the seating will be
socially distanced as well uh our groups
no more than six people to a group much
like when you're going out to have
dinner
and then we're going to have everybody
socially distanced apart and we're going
to be at the 10
capacity that's been set down by the
state government
are tickets still available for for the
drag races up there people want to check
out the racing
is that still possible no we actually
have uh
uh have exhausted our entire allotment
of tickets to meet that 10 percent
capacity
we don't have any tickets for the race
we don't have any camping spaces
available
we also don't have any what we call our
club nitro which is sort of a
hospitality area that we serve food and
we have driver appearances and even the
driver appearances
in club nitro are all going to be
virtual this year you know
between the the speedway and you know
t-mobile arena allegiance
all of the major sporting events want to
have fans back in obviously
um is this maybe a playbook what you're
having up at the speedway that other
events maybe can have
down the line as we try to get through
this pandemic you think
well i hope so i mean i will tell you
that we take a great responsibility in
being the first venue
to host fans i can tell you we're also
rooting for unlv and allegiant stadium
on saturday night
to be able to have fans in a successful
manner i'm not sure what t-mobile's
plans are but all the other venues in
town
and not just the sports facilities but
the showrooms uh the smith center and
what myron martin and his group down
there trying to put together
we really really want to see people
getting back to going to events
whether it be a sporting event or a
concert or
a broadway play or whatever it is and
we're taking a great responsibility at
being the first ones to do it and doing
it right
and finally just back on track here we
mentioned you mentioned last time we
spoke it's the mhra finals usually
they're
out in pomona this time they're going to
be in las vegas for the 10
of the fans that are going to get to see
it or anyone who watches on tv what's on
tap there and what should
people be watching for in the different
classes
well we'll have the sportsman classes
today on friday we normally run pros on
friday we'll have
qualifying on saturday at 1 p.m and 4
p.m and then sunday the finals start at
10 a.m
and we're going to be crowning champions
and we've got some of the biggest stars
in all of drag racing
uh steve torrance is going to probably
be the favorite in the in the top fuel
the funny car we got a number of guys
but jack beckman and matt hagen and
tommy johnson jr are going to be the top
three guys
in that division but you're going to see
cars that are going 330 miles an hour
in a thousand feet and that's just
incredible 300 miles an hour i i've
heard that's
fast jeff uh thank you very much i don't
think i don't think you go that fast in
your go-kart
no no no i know as much as i've tried
jeff it just doesn't
i can barely crack 50. jeff thanks for
joining us again this morning good luck
this weekend we'll touch base with you
later on